bonsoir à tous nous sommes le lundi 2
novembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
votre actualité locale accompagnés de
nos invités et des journalistes de la
rédaction
ou comment se suit avec les titres de
cette édition le président du sénat
sénateurs de rambouillet cet amour pas
pour un échange avec le premier
magistrat de la ville au menu de cette
rencontre de travail
la nouvelle intercommunalité l'avenir de
la piscine municipale ou encore la
création d'un nouveau cinéma pour ce
week-end de la toussaint un crématorium
un crématorium a décidé d'ouvrir ses
portes celui des murs ou la crémation
choisi par plus de 30 % de la population
aujourd'hui si enfin huit jeunes
inscrits auprès de la mission locale de
plaisir ont participé à un trek en
irlande l'objectif ceux confrontés à des
obstacles afin de mieux réussir leur vie
professionnelle en plateau nous en
parlerons dans quelques instants
et pour ouvrir cette édition cette
information dunlopillo restera dans les
yvelines lusine de matelas va déménager
de monte la jolie mais s'installera à
limay et aussi à porcheville mercredi 28
octobre l'établissement public foncier
des yvelines a signé l'acte
d'acquisition le site dunlopillo dans le
quartier de gassicourt à mantes-la-jolie
318 emploi et vu moi sont donc sauvés
le département avait investi près de 10
millions d'euros sur ce projet il était
en discussion depuis de nombreux mois
afin que l'usiné ne se délocalisent pas
dans le nord de la france et enfin
vendredi dernier gérard larcher
président du sénat et sénateur des
yvelines était à maurepas pour un dîner
de travail avec grégory dia astier le
maire de la commune
les deux élus ont ainsi échangé autour
de plusieurs problématiques de la ville
l'entrée dans la casse qui au mois de
janvier le centre nautique
le projet de cinéma ou encore l'impact
de la baisse des dotations décidées par
le gouvernement
les explications avec mélanie potiche le
centre nautique de maurepas et l'une des
problématiques connu par la commune
cette année
c'est l'une des raisons de la présence
de gérard larcher vendredi dernier le
président du sénat était venu échanger
avec le maire de la commune
autre sujet de discussion le projet de
cinéma nos repas soutenue par la
commission nationale d'aménagement
commercial
le permis de construire est en cours
d'instruction et donc il sera délivré
avant la fin d'année pour je n'espère
livraison début 2010 est parce qu il est
nécessaire à la survie de la zone
village des loisirs
ces présidents le chaînage qu'on l'a
bien compris là dessus et c'est une
attente forte aussi pour le pour le pour
le pour le secteur pour nos
investisseurs pour dynamiser pour près
de la richesse et de l'emploi
ces projets s'inscrivent notamment dans
la question de la future intégration
janvier 2016 de maurepas dans la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nos repas est
l'une des cinq communes à entrer dans la
caisse qui quand une à dire qu connaît
des modifications de limites c'est le
cas en plus scandé on ans dans une
interview très intégré ce qui est le cap
l'agglomération de saint quentin et
qu'en même temps les règles du jeu
oblige à revoir une partie des
compétences et notamment à les élargir
sa loi est l'occasion de refonder en
quelque sorte un certain nombre de
projets et ce qui compte dans une
interface et le projet le territoire
lors de cette rencontre les objectifs de
25 % de logements sociaux ont aussi été
abordés le maire a annoncé le choix de
la construction d'un écoquartier avec 30
% de logements sociaux et ce soir nous
accueillons en plateau deux invités
bonsoir à vous de mesdames alors
véronique dire non vous êtes présidente
de la mission locale de plaisir val de
dialyse et vous êtes venu nous parler
donc d'un coaching trek en irlande
auquel participent sonia generosity là
également nous en parler alors ce trek
c'est du 10 ou 17 novembre en irlande 25
km par jour à pied et l'idée si si je ne
me trompe pas c'est d'amener en fait des
jeunes accomplir un parcours semé
d'embûches avec des sacs de rando avait
voilà des petits bars comme ça pour
mieux réussir leur parcours qui les
mènera vers une insertion
professionnelle
alors cette idée est née comment alors
les partis d'un constat
on a remarqué qu'à la mission locale la
plupart des jeunes inscrits rencontré
des difficultés pour s'engager dans la
durée des démarches vers la stations
professionnelles ou sociales
donc ce qui est dommage parce qu'il ya
un certain qu'ils abandonnent sur leur
formation ou sur leur poste alors priori
qui leur plaisait et puis on constate en
effet que ça manque de confiance en soi
donc l'idée l'idée de ce périple sportif
le coaching trek est venu justement pour
se doter d'un mental de gagnant voilà de
base et donc sur la solidarité sur la
négation de soi sur la gestion de la
botte de l'impondérable de l'assaut de
la solidarité de manière à pouvoir
réaliser de pouvoir atteindre un
objectif celui de parcours de parcourir
chaque jour 25 km à pied sac à dos et
donc du coup alors vous vous y
réfléchissez depuis de l'année 2015 ça
fait quelques mois que vous avez mis ça
en place pour ça se passe sans que là le
10 novembre
vous avez recruté un petit peu faim
recruter si on peut dire les jeunes
comment alors il ya eu une requête en
effet mais tous se sont volontaires bien
sûr par rapport en effet un parcours
semé d'embûches semer
ou le vecteur important est le manque de
confiance en soi sans qu'il y ait de
grosses difficultés mais simplement
faire basculer avoir le déclic qui
permet justement au travers d'un périple
sportif de les aider à déverrouiller ce
déclic et avoir vraiment confiance en
soi en ayant réalisé ce parcours semé
d'embûches comme celui qui est celui
lorsqu'on veut atteindre
l'insertion professionnelle donc au
travers d'une formation ou de se
présenter un recruteur d'arsenal
généreuse et vous participez donc à ce
trek
qu'est ce qui vous a plu en fait dans
cette idée poids vous ai dit voilà je
vais postuler pour faire partie de cette
aventure
alors pour rejoindre d'idées de la
présidente
le fait de pouvoir partir à des
kilomètres et de se dire que que
justement on va pouvoir consolider cet
esprit des clips là surtout comparé avec
plusieurs gènes on ne connaît pas tous
forcément donc de savoir que quand on
est justement dans notre ville
ça change un peu l'univers
oui voilà donc du coup la de partir et
de se dire qu'on va pouvoir être
solidaire on va rencontrer des obstacles
du coup d affronter ensemble et se dire
que voilà c'est ça c'est un beau projet
qui vous a donné envie de envie de venir
alors pourquoi je vais avoir choisi en
trek et pourquoi aussi loin en irlande
on aurait pu penser peut-être aller en
france ailleurs oui c'est une très bonne
question
alors coaching trek ou développement de
soi au travers d'un périple sportif
pourquoi l'irlande
tout simplement parce que l'irlande est
quand même pas loin de la france moi ce
que je souhaitais c'est vraiment qu'il y
ait une coupure avec l'environnement
pour ces jeunes
et puis l'irlande
les lourdes d'histoire elle est riche en
culture en traditions et puis à la
langue qui est là aussi qui peut être
aussi un obstacle alors il ya une
spécificité tous les jeunes ont un rôle
c'est vraiment eux qui s'organise et qui
vont se gérer où l'on se traite à huy un
chacun donc huit jeunes
huit jeunes dont 4,5 de plaisir de de
villepreux un des clayes-sous-bois et
chacun ces huit jeunes sont préposés à
une action de travail bien particulière
alors il y en a qui est préposé aux
transports l'autre au budget un autre
dans l'hôtellerie la sécurité voilà
chacun a une responsabilité et cette
spécificité dans ce trekking coach c'est
juste coaching trek parle beaucoup c'est
que chacun a les jeunes le groupe de
jeunes préparent de a à z le périple est
donc vous souvenir oisifs vous occupez
de quoi donc pour rentrer alors moi je
suis plus on m'a chargé de m'occuper
alors tout ce qui est vie sur place en
fait donc quand on sera là bas
la passion dont on sera hébergée quand
enfin commencer vous avez alors on fait
des recherches sur internet ou deux pour
voir enfin d'essayer de préparer le
projet correctement ensemble et vous
aviez déjà fait ça avant c'était un peu
une grande première
c'est la première fois c'était compliqué
vous avez senti que vous avez déjà
apporté des choses au niveau de
l'organisation peut-être que vous aviez
peut-être pas l'habitude vous avez de
penser à autre chose prendre certaines
certains éléments un peu en moins ou
être mieux organisé par exemple il y
avait toute manière le groupe de coach à
côté puisqu'il ya trois adultes qui va
être attendu qui vont accompagner ce
groupe de vie jaune donc il y avait ce
cadre qui permettait à chacun de pouvoir
prendre le bon cap dans leurs recherches
et l'action et venir un peu d'un constat
que justement sont enfin est ce que vous
avez peut-être refaire ça plus tard
enfin comment ça se passe à un peu aussi
sur place voici une deuxième édition en
termes d'action tout à fait atypique à
la mise sur le call de plaisir c'est
qu'il ya deux ans en 2013 on avait fait
le temps d'émotion voilà donc c'était un
tandem avec un jeune de la mission de
call volontaire et derrière un mal
voyants malvoyants de l'association avis
et c'est vrai que là c'était un défi qui
était donné et là c'est pareil sur le
même principe
c'est un défi que chaque jeune se donne
c'est vraiment une action différente de
celle que vous faites une action
différente mais toujours toujours le
point central de chacun c'est la remise
en confiance ce soin est toute l'année
vous faites voilà des actions de ce type
c'est vraiment la confiance en soi est
vraiment au centre des préoccupations
absolument et qui est ce que vous
attendez quoi fin de des jeunes qui
prennent conscience de quoi après ce
trek là qu'il reprenne mon sang neuf
mais peut être autre chose a également
acquis réussissent d'abord qui réalise
d'abord ils vont partir à huit
ils vont venir à 8 ils vont apprendre
je suis sûr qu'ils vont revenir dotée
d'un capital confiance
en tout cas plus important par rapport à
celui qu'ils connaissent aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont connaître leur potentiel
potentiel de battants de combattants
depuis avec des valeurs qui vont se
développer telles que la solidarité la
négation de soi
l'encouragement aussi et puis je suis
sûr que ça va débloquer dès sa va
déverrouiller quelques quelques clés car
j'en suis certaine fait d'accord ça ya
pensé très bas vous attendez quoi vous
pensez vous qu'après pour vous
débrouiller dans n'importe quelle
situation
c'est ce qu'on souhaite en tout cas
c'est vrai que des fois c'est pas
vraiment évident dans la vie de tous les
jours que ce soit dans les démarches et
là de se dire qu'on va peut-être pouvoir
travailler sur ça et de revenir et de
revenir avec mon entraîneur je sais moi
pour rejoindre pour 25 m par jour ça ne
va pas me préparer j'étais là justement
il ya un jeune qui est en responsabilité
pour l'entraînement si vous y tenez
voilà et c'est vrai que par rapport
justement ces jeunes répondre à votre
question c'est que ils vont revenir
grandit bien sûr avoir réalisé on les
nomme rappaz comme pour chacun comme
quelqu'un qui est en échec qu'il ya des
difficultés de parcours mais grandi de
sept
de ceux de cette belle de ce beau
périple et qui leur permettra en effet
d'être identifié comme quelqu'un qui a
réussi qui s'est réalisé et donc vous
partez donc je le rappel du 10 au 17
novembre en irlande alors peut-être nous
en reparlerons après une fois que vous
ayez vous avez fait donc ce trek revenir
sur l'expérience à voir ce que vous a
apporté en tout cas merci beaucoup mais
damned est revenue en place au avec nous
pour y puiser et la journée des défunts
c'est aujourd'hui le lundi 2 novembre
pour l'occasion le crématorium des murs
organisé ses portes ouvertes à
l'occasion de la fête de la toussaint ce
week-end ouvert en 2010 l'établissement
est de plus en plus sollicité par les
familles c'est le seul crématorium des
yvelines environ 1000 défunt ils sont
incinérés chaque année fanny bourdon et
william l voilà donc ici se trouve la
salle technique avec donc l'appareil de
crémation donc nous plaçons le cercle
juste ici le cercle justicier ensuite
nous le voulons il ya des bras qui se
lève
nous le relevons le cercueil hauteur ou
la porte s'ouvre nous plaçons le
cercueil directement dans l'appareil de
crémation ce sont nous ressortons
ensuite les bras nous refermons la porte
simplement ce dimanche le crématorium
des mureaux le seul du département a
organisé ses portes ouvertes
l'occasion de rassurer les visiteurs
quant à la crémation qui peut en
inquiéter certains
j'avais pas besoin d'être rassurés
c'était surtout mon épouse qui avait
besoin de l'être dans la mesure où son
choix aujourd'hui pourrait
aller vers la crémation alors qu'il ya
quelques temps c'était plus l'animation
classique c'était justement pour y
réfléchir parce que je n'avais jamais
assisté à aucune crémation est
finalement ben ça me faisait peur ça me
faisait très peur et maintenant après
avoir vu les lieux
c'est pas si terrible que ça en fait les
mentalités ont changé aujourd'hui près
d'un tiers des obsèques passe par une
crémation
alors qu'elles ne représentaient qu'un
pour cent à la fin des années 70 les
crémations depuis effectivement une
trentaine d'années sont en hausse
nous en moyenne dans cet établissement
nous effectuons en moyenne 1000
crémation à peu près c'est un chiffre
qui est en hausse chaque année une
crémation va coûter de toute façon bien
sûr moins cher qu'un caveau dans un
cimetière un caveau de plusieurs places
finalement la crémation coûtera moins
cher plus économique
facturé aux alentours de 700 euros moins
d'entretien la création de nombreux
avantages pour le personnel de cet
établissement
il faut prendre le temps d'y réfléchir
avant et c'est une fête qui connaît un
regain d'intérêt depuis plusieurs années
la fête d'halloween dont les origines
remontent à la tradition celtique attire
les français qui aiment se déguiser à
voisins le bretonneux c'est une armée de
petits monstres qui s'est abattue sur la
ville samedi soir avec pour seul
objectif effrayer les riverains c'est
que notre journaliste william l
regardez je veux entendre du bruit on
pouvait vendre et c'est une nuée de
sorcières vampires vont billets loup
garou qui ont envahi l'espace de covile
samedi soir à voisins le bretonneux pour
halloween le parc à des pris les allures
de cimetière un cimetière où les morts
n'étaient pas vraiment de nouveauté
halloween d'été d'exemple coin
conduit par son immortel est rigolo
parce qu'ils perdent leurs membres des
déguisés en quoi là parce que j'aime
bien et ça fait peur le zombie d'un
déguisement qui fait fureur cette année
les morts-vivants ont la cote même chez
les organisateurs
certains espaces du site semble tout
droit sorti de film d'horreur bien connu
en fête halloween c'est devenu très très
large avant c'était juste une fête où on
pensait que comme vous on était pile
poil 2 entre le jour et la nuit c'était
la frontière parfaite entre la mort et
la vie
et puis petit à petit enrichi de tout le
cinéma fantastique c'est devenu sert
donc on joue vraiment avec ce avec ce
cliché là et ont fait voyager les gens
d'ambiance en ambiance avec des choses
plus ou moins effrayante et surtout
marrant tu as maximum plusieurs
activités ludiques qui était organisée
par les associations partenaires
spectacle de magie compte mystique ou
atelier maquillage et au détour de
chaque buisson il n'était pas rare de
croiser des friands personnage c'est
très très faim j'ai très très faim et
j'adore manger une fois tu vois ça là ça
c'est le foie et je veux que tu me la
trappe
c'est très très très très détaillée fait
en latex et si jamais on touche les
bords comme pour les docteurs en agaune
ya un klaxon qui s'allument
c'est un peu vicieux mais y'a tout chez
il a touché les morts vous inventez le
klaxon voilà mais c'est très très
difficile faire peur ou avoir peur telle
est la question même si pour les enfants
halloween rime surtout avec friandises
quel que soit l'âge ce soir personne
n'échappe aux déguisements
j'ai fait l'effort de me déguiser enfin
une petite bêtise
ah voilà des petites petites phrases
comme ça on fait une soirée avec des
copains et on fait le tour des maisons
et là on s'est dit qu'on allait avoir
comme point de chute ici parce que
j'étais très sympa halloween à voisins
le bretonneux une fête conviviale qui
rassemble toute la famille autour d'un
imaginaire commun et avec son large
sourire et son teint orange impossible
de la rater car la star de la soirée
c'était tel et rentreront mais combien
et comme chaque lundi nous retrouvons
sephora namani pour la chronique culture
bonsoir sephora danseurs florane alors
ce soit nous allons parler ensemble
histoire
quels souvenirs avez-vous des cours
d'histoire du collège gilles van kote
j'en ai de bons souvenirs surtout le
programme de troisième il faut dire que
j'avais de bons professeurs bien vous
êtes bien chanceuse parce que ce n'est
pas la marge de ce n'est pas l'avis
partagé par la majorité des collégiens
ce n'est pas non plus le constat qu'a
fait vianney malin commissaire du salon
histoire de lire qui tente par ce salon
qui réunit 150 historiens de vulgariser
l'histoire de la rendre plus accessible
au public en général et particulièrement
aux gènes ont l'écoutent
à partir de 12 13 ans les enfants
étaient moins intéressés par la lecture
et ne venaient pas à notre salon donc
avec l'aide du conseil départemental
nous avons décidé d'envoyer en quelque
sorte les historiens en mission donc
allez rencontrer les classes de 4e et de
et de troisième alors en vue de ce salon
justement l'association histoire de lire
en partenariat avec le conseil
départemental des yvelines a donc
missionné un historien pour venir rendre
attractif l'histoire et donc nous étions
ce matin au collège louis pasteur avec
une classe de 4e et l'historien présents
étaient dimitri caselli je vais vous
raconter l'histoire non petit immigré
qui peut arriver en france
de 10 ans en parler un seul mot de
français
peut-être que certains sont arrivés dans
un pays un peu comme napoléon il parlait
pas un traître mot de français et il est
devenu grâce à sa volonté à sa force de
travail les devenu le fondateur de la
france moderne et de toutes les
institutions qui régissent la france
aujourd'hui
alors le thème de la conférence portait
sur un napoléon l'a entendu est ce qu'il
y avait une raison particulière à ce
choix alors il y avait deux raisons
c'est que la première et les conférences
respecte le programme en fête des
collégiens au cours de l'année et puis
la seconde c'est qu'on cherche à a parlé
de grandes figures historiques auxquels
les collégiens ans peuvent s'identifier
et également dimitri casali a été
professeur à cergy-saint-christophe
d'histoire pendant dix ans et puis il
avait du mal à capter l'attention de ses
élèves alors c'est pourquoi il a
développé une méthode pédagogique un peu
spécial qui l'a baptisé historique est
lui aussi nous l'avons rencontré j'ai
compris qu'il fallait utiliser tous les
moyens possibles autour de moi pour leur
transmettre le goût de l'histoire c'est
à dire bien sûr le récit j'assiste
beaucoup sur la raconter des histoires
des petites histoires de l'histoire de
france est assistée sur lui mars ce sont
les femmes et les hommes qui font
l'histoire et enfin d'autres d'autres
vecteurs comme la musique rock rap
reggae les enfants aux personnages
historiques de napo lyon il a écrit une
chanson autour de ce personnage qu'il a
décliné musicalement alors pourquoi
napoléon parce que napoléon en fait
c'est un immigré qui est né à ajaccio
qui ne parlait pas un mot de français au
début et qui grâce à son talent et à son
mérite et son courage a bâti un empire
c'est le cas de le dire
alors avec ses chansons il a même fait
un album pour apprendre l'histoire de
façon ludique aux enfants exactement
alors il a créé des albums il a écrit
des livres est également il ya même créé
deux spectacles un sur l'antiquité 1 sur
napoléon pour lequel d'ailleurs il
n'hésite pas à revêtir le costume du
hussard sur scène accompagné d'un
chanteur façon freddie mercury un autre
guitariste un bassiste et un pianiste
m
ça nous aidera beaucoup
de temps en temps
prendre
mais oui c'est un enseignement beaucoup
plus moderne c'est lequel lui dirai ce
que les jeunes sont réceptifs
alors écoutez ce matin en tout cas on a
vraiment senti les collégiens intéressés
et réceptifs à la conférence
ils ont même eu la chance de se voir
offrir à la fin un ouvrage le livre le
grand album l'histoire de france de
notre enfance de dimitri casali et
guillaume bourgeonnent qui était
dédicacé à leur nom c'est donc un bilan
positif pour cette action soutenue par
le conseil départemental des yvelines
qui souhaite l'étendre à tous les
collèges du département journée que
l'histoire c'est une matière vivante
d'une manière passionnant mais ils sont
tout de même bien indispensable pour
préparer son avenir voilà
l'apprentissage de la citoyenneté ne
peut se faire qu'à partir de ce goût de
l'histoire parce que l'histoire ça nous
permet de mieux comprendre le présent de
mieux anticiper le futur alors quatre
conférences du type auront lieu avant le
salon histoire de lire sur versailles et
saint cyr animés par différents
historiens en direction toujours des
scolaires et je le rappelle le salon
histoire de lire se tiendra les 21 et 22
novembre prochains à l'hôtel de ville de
versailles qui lui sera ouvert au public
bien quel dommage que nous soyons plus
au collège merci sephora on vous
retrouve mercredi pour une nouvelle
édition en kiosques le magazine consacré
à la culture à présent un point sur la
transat jacques vabre vous le savez le
skipper versailles et tombe de la mode
participe actuellement à la compétition
le navigateur est parti avec sa
coéquipière samantha davies le dimanche
25 octobre du port du havre à bord de
son imoca initiative coeur victime d'une
avarie vendredi dernier le skipper a
réussi à réparer son bateau ils pointent
actuellement à la 5e place du classement
et vise même la quatrième place une
écoute tout de suite les skippers
versailles est encore notre la
comprennent pas encore là beaucoup de
cas
sur notre bateau mais aussi sur les
autres donc il y en a beaucoup qui ont
fait demi tour
nous on est encore là sort du brésil
donc c'est vraiment super on a fait un
début pour tâter musclé mais mais on est
con les comptes en mai en donne port
dont on est dans un bon rythme et on est
on est très contents d'être là où on est
dans classement et d'être surtout encore
une fois tu relis c'est une course pour
la bonne cause chaque clic sur la page
officielle initiative coeur le sponsor
de ton dit de la mode permet de récolter
des dons pour sauver des enfants
cardiaques des enfants atteint d'une
malformation cardiaque pardon le site
apparaît à l'écran en ce moment pour le
moment la traversée de ton dit va
permettre à treize enfants d'être sauvé
siens et pour finir nous restons sur le
sport le rugby club de plaisir n'en
finit plus de gagner les yvelinois
poursuivre leur sans-faute dans le
championnat de fédérale 3 ils ont
largement dominé ce week-end l'équipe de
reuil malmaison le score 28 à 15
conséquence plaisir est le premier du
classement
résumé du match avec michael et demi
d'euros et william l quatrième match et
quatrième victoire pour plaisir en
fédérale 3 ce dimanche il est rugbyman
yves in one ont une nouvelle fois pas
fait de détail à domicile face avant et
même maison le score est sans appel 28 à
c'est vrai que quatre matches quatre
victoires on va pas non plus faire la
fine bouche c'est vrai mais voilà et on
est toujours un petit peu un temps qu'un
entraîneur on n'est jamais satisfait
complètement médias comme la victoire il
faut pas l'oublier 28 15 il vit paru
emporter 10 sièges zéro point c'est donc
on écrit mme chocat satisfait du
résultat on peut non plus être trop trop
pessimiste avec cette victoire plaisir
caracole en tête du championnat avec 17
points et 119 points marqués depuis le
début de la saison et sont dues en
fédérale 3 après un passage éclair à
l'échelon supérieur plaisir veut
remonter dès cette année on va se donner
les moyens durant toute la saison
jusqu'au bout quoi parce que bon on voit
avec le score d'aujourd'hui où il y aura
aucun match qui sera gagné jusqu'à la
fin de saison il y aura pas un match
facile y aura pas une équipe qui lâchera
on sait qu'en fédérale 3 c'est ce besoin
nieuws assassi fil sur tous les impacts
et est du coup bah voilà le score
reflète la partie quand et la saison ce
sera comme ça jusqu'au bout donc faudra
qu'on accroche crise que le club s'était
quand même à bien figurer un dernier en
fédérale 2 il est il avait perdu juste
sur gagne à la dernière rencontre donc
bien sûr que les joueurs allaient en vie
et l'objectif seul objectif clair c'est
quand même de remonter immédiatement
fédérale 2 mais on va produire autre
chose que ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
prochain match pour les yvelinois
dimanche 8 novembre à l'extérieur contre
marcq en baroeul le dauphin de plaisir
au classement et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivis tout
de suite rester avec nous vous avez
rendez vous avec michael almy d'euros et
ses invités pour le cepd sport à leur
programme il ya du football du rugby et
même du bric du billard c'est à ne pas
rater fond ma part je vous retrouve
demain à 18 heures pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal en direct je
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée